this is a network engineer they have
on-prem experience and are new to
setting up networking in Google Cloud
they have been tasked with exploring and
understanding how to create a network in
their organization's environment with
dual stack subnets they need to get a
better understanding of how networking
Works in Google cloud and are hoping to
use duet AI to help them create a custom
VPC with dual stack subnets let's
observe this network engineer as they
use duet AI to simplify the task at hand
first things first they want to know how
to set up a virtual private cloud or VPC
in Google Cloud they go to Google search
look for VPC on Google Cloud scroll
through documentation watch a video read
a bit more here and there and they get
frustrated and decide to take a quick
coffee break to clear their head after
lamenting their frustrations to a
coworker they recommend a potential
solution try duet AI it's an AI
companion that saves time especially in
these situations thanks helpful coworker
let's open duet Ai and see if it can
help speed things along they prompt duet
AI to help them understand how to create
a VPC Network in Google Cloud duet AI
responds and the network engineer is
amazed they recall that they want to
ensure that the subnet created here is
dual stack so they ask duet to adjust
the g-cloud command to ensure the subnet
created is dual stack they are happy and
excited that duet aai responded with
that modification for dual stack now
they are ready to proceed with setting
up this VPC and making it a reality they
used the g-cloud command duet provided
and then create the dual stack Subnet in
that VPC using the g-cloud command duet
AI provided they are amazed and thrilled
that their VPC and subnets are created
now that the VPC is set up our network
engineer is interested in learning more
about connecting Google Cloud to their
on Prem Network because they have
applications running on premises that
they would like to connect to the ones
running in Google Cloud for this they'll
need to have some sort of private
connectivity between their on-prem
Network and Google Cloud so they decide
to use duet AI to assist them with
understanding the options available to
them duet AI responds with instructions
on how to connect a VPC and Google Cloud
to an on premises private Network while
helpful to know that they can use
cloudvpn tunnels or V attachments with
Cloud interconnect they'd like to get a
more detailed comparison to help them
make a decision so they prompt du at AI
which they should use and as to provide
details supporting the use of each
according to their respective strengths
duet ai's response includes a helpful
comparison visual along with more
context as well as additional factors to
consider when making their decision duet
AI is amazing this is now their new
exploration and learning tool they
decide to keep going with this now
they'd like to use duet AI to explore
DNS in Google Cloud they prompt duet AI
to help them understand networking in
Google cloud and ask how does DNS work
in Google Cloud duet AI response and the
network engineer is pleased to get all
this information in context without
having to contact switch and leave the
console since they know they already
have primary private DNS resolution on
premises they'd like to use duet AI to
help them understand if this is possible
to integrate with Google Cloud DNS so
they prompt to AI with a question asking
how DNS forwarding Works between Google
Cloud DNS and potential on premises
private DNS servers duet responds with
context as well as advice on how to go
about configuring DNS forwarding from
this response they gather that
forwarding zones in Google Cloud DNS
provides the functionality they need and
they can follow up by clicking the show
related content button in which official
documentation is linked for them to
learn more about configuring forwarding
zones ah but why stop their quest for
knowledge there the network engineer
would like to understand IP addressing
in Google Cloud so they asked to Ed AI
once again wonderful this information is
useful context for our network engineer
since their team requires both
ipv4 and IPv6 support they'd also like
to understand if they can run a dual
stack Subnet in Google Cloud so they
prompt duet AI with the question duet a
responds with some helpful info yes you
can and it provides a link to the docs
with more info and with all that time
saved they can now finally get around to
exploring science thanks du AI what will
you
[Music]
build